you're breaking up with me I seriously
can't believe this is happening right
now I'm sorry but it's over it's just
the way it's gonna be I thought we'd be
together forever wrong we had a great
time all right but I didn't picture us
ending up together we're perfect for
each other I already started shopping
for rings and looking for places where
we can have our wedding reception this
is the type of stuff that really bugs me
I mean you're fast forwarding our
relationship we don't even have a
wedding in you're planning one you're
picking baby names baby clothes so I
want a family sue me I want the American
Dream the white picket fence the station
wagon the tire swing I want a golden
retriever named Max and yeah what the
family portrait where we're all wearing
matching denim you are crazy
are you hearing yourself right now this
is the type of stuff I cannot commit to
I got to focus on my career time is
going I wanted to what I want when I
want want to hang out with my girls on
the weekend I want to be settled down
and tied up to some ball and chain ball
and chain ball and chain ball and chain
that's what you think of me then I'm
just some weight some burden in your
life that's holding you back from
accomplishing your dreams I guess I
guess you don't know me that well after
all yeah well I guess you don't know me
either
whatever don't whatever be a man I am a
man I guess you're not the woman I
thought you were oh I'm more woman than
you can handle
oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah we're through that's
right we are